[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Applause]
but I'm looking at please
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you went together here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the cast of
Avengers infinity war
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please help me welcome Joe and Anthony
Russo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sabes it could destroy life on Christ
we're gonna need some help together it's
our only hope
it's pretty amazing to be here yeah
we've got you know everywhere you look
you see a star from the Marvel Universe
it's been ten years in the making this
film coming together it's truly an
unprecedented cinematic event and yeah I
know we're all thrilled to be here
it's so crazy man and even for like
Robert Downey jr. this is crazy that's
how crazy this is
I was really Merlin right how are you
feeling man he's like dude this is
insane
and when Robert Downey jr. says
something's insane it's definitely gonna
be a crazy day to be a part of it in any
shape or form is a blessing I gotta say
this a real nostalgic kind of vibe going
on I feel an emotional more than any
other film or premiere I've been to have
somehow magically honored like all these
separate franchises in one single film
it's kind of crazy how they did it ready
let's go
seeing how this mumps upon mumps of
secrecy has now you know been pieced
together and come together so really
excited about it these movies are very
communal for us everyone that we work
with it's like a family we love all the
actors we love Marvel Disney it's a
great experience when we all get to come
together and share these movies but it's
really why we make them as good
we love sharing them with the fans
they've never seen all of their favorite
characters interact and that's I think
what's special about this movie also
they've never seen a villain like Thanos
before and we're very excited audiences
to experience them it's pretty amazing
to go all over the world and see the
same enthusiasm in love and support you
know you know mobile friends to the best
and when you see that around the world
you know it's a very it's a good family
to all so far I'm in full anticipation
right now because we haven't seen it
there's a lot of stuff that we don't
know the anticipation is huge even with
the actors I can't wait I cannot wait is
the first time my life that I've I've
done press and I've gotten this far
without seeing the film that I'm in so
I've been I've been a nervous wreck all
weekend but I've also been super excited
like any fan to see it nobody see the
movie I don't know how to Russo brothers
who lets them get away with this and
actually did it without give me anybody
the full script so almost exactly ten
years ago we were right in the same spot
debuting Iron Man 1 the notion that in
10 years we would be on film number 19
having introduced so many the iconic
characters and now culminated in a film
like infinity war it's overwhelming and
I actually still can't believe it
the end
[Applause]
point undone half of humanity will still
exist
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]